welcome back spinal care of nevada who
is the sponsor of this next segment
offers complete chiropractic care and
here to tell us more about their gentle
form of care is dr devin welcome back to
the show hey buddy great to be here it's
great to have you back in studio so
let's talk about it what is nuka okay so
nuka is a very gentle style of
chiropractic you know if you if you've
been to a chiropractor and you like the
twisting cracking popping i'm probably
not the right guy you're not the guy
okay so nuka is a very gentle style
where we adjust the top of the neck
area called your brainstem brainstem
controls everything it's like my wife
tells you what to do where to go how to
do it and i listen
so by getting pressure off that we help
things like headaches migraines neck
pain and by rebalancing the head and
neck it helps everything else go
underneath straight again so even things
like low back pain sciatica burning
nerves into the feet let's see how it
works you brought it in here we've been
watching all summer long with your
segments and now it is in studio we
treat uh kids in the office too they
nickname it the woodpecker the sound it
makes yes so this is the secondary type
of uh adjustment we do we can go into
like you know that hump on the back of
people's back yeah nickname the dowage
or something and go in and tap tap tap
tap how about pain right in between the
shoulder blades tap tap tap if you have
degenerative disc disease where the disc
is worn down this helps open those
spaces up right into the lower back
sciatica low back pain
disc problems it's a it feels incredible
doesn't hurt it's very non-invasive and
helps relieve pain now there's people
that have surgery before they come see
you and they don't need surgery after
the fact
we see people who've been through rods
plates screws um even minor surgeries
who've been told hey never go see a
chiropractor but because our techniques
are very gentle non-invasive or the the
md's that refer to us call it low force
we can treat patients who even have rods
plates and screws in their back now yeah
someone just cannot walk right in and
get your services you can you do a
two-day building we're a little more
thorough yes i love that this is great
you're right there so you're looking for
the stop in get a crack not the right
guy for you so we do a two-day workup
and on the screen this is a nerve chart
which shows if we adjust the middle back
that's the nerve that goes to the
stomach and if you adjust the upper back
that's the nerve that can even run to
the heart and the lungs so i don't claim
to cure breathing problems and heart
problems but if you get the pressure off
of these nerves that can run everything
in the entire body now what are some of
the areas that you treat you mentioned
migraines what are some if people have
symptoms at home what do you treat so in
the two day work up we're going to
examine you from head to toe you come
with neck pain we're going to check the
back too because that's all part of it
so day one thorough history exam
consultation we'll take digital x-rays
best type of films in my field i wish
more people would take them
day two we're gonna go over all the
findings okay and i'm real
straightforward if i can't help someone
i'm gonna get them to the right doctor
if i can we're real up front we're gonna
go over time cost coverage everything
and get to work that's what i like about
you 99 of the time you're going to help
someone but if you can't for some reason
you're not gonna make it
to the right spot yep i love it i
appreciate you coming back in studio dr
david my pleasure for being here one
more time give us a shot okay so the
woodpecker here we're going up the bones
and again we do the two-day workup um
normally it's 180. for the first 20
callers we give it to them for 37
beautiful and i'm just watching you do
it it seems very gentle almost relaxing
to watch this it is
people who are afraid of going to
chiropractors or god forbid have been
hurt at chiropractors or other
physicians offices they come see us
because it's so gentle and safe perfect
thank you dr devin we appreciate it
spinal care in nevada they've got two
locations summerlin and henderson and
you can reach them at
702-566-hope that's 4673 or go to
drdevin.com two-day work-up including
digital x-rays for 37 that's normally
180
this is for the first 20 callers not
valid for those eligible for federal
benefits